-One of the reasons
that makes sense to me,
both that you would write
and want to direct it,
is it´s so personal,
and one of the things
that was interesting to me
is you obviously set it closer
to when you grew up?
-Yeah.
And so no cellphones, which was
such a fun thing to watch,
a high school movie where
cellphones is not a plot point.
-I know. You could not know
where someone was.
-Yeah.
-Which is amazing.
-Yeah, and so much more helpful
for storytelling that you --
-Yes. Yeah.
For any story, it´s good
to not know where anybody is.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It´s a good thing.
-Well, because usually
huge plot points
are either
that person showing up or --
-Yes. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-So, no, it was -- I actually --
I like on my film sets
and now I can say that,
my one film set,
but -- I like -- nobody has
cellphones anyway.
I don´t like having cellphones
on set
because I think it helps
the actors to concentrate.
But I had a young cast,
like, you know, 18 to 22.
There were a lot of young people
and everyone was like,
"Good luck with that."
Like, "they´ll never give up
those phones,"
but I sold it to them as being
about it´s an acting thing.
-Oh, and they bought in?
-Yeah.
And I was like,
"This is for your acting."
[ Laughter ]
And they were like, "Oh, great!"
-You also -- I thought this was
really cool.
You have people -- you had
your crew wear name tags?
-Yes.
-And not just their name.
There would be
a different question --
A different answer every day?
-Yeah, well, there was a --
I had everyone wear name tags
because I feel like for actors,
especially, if you´re coming in
for like a day or two days,
it´s hard to get
to know everyone,
and it made everybody a person.
So I had a name tag.
Everybody had a name tag.
And then our -- there was a P.A.
who was wonderful, Dayna,
who came up with the question of
the day every day.
And it would be a trivia
question
or sort of like
a conversation starter,
like, "what was
your go-to karaoke song?"
Or "what what would you do
if you didn´t do this?"
Or "what is a movie that you
know you should like
but you don´t?"
-What was a movie that you know
you should like but you don´t?
-"Breakfast at Tiffany´s."
-Oh, wow!
It´s so beautiful,
but there´s something about it
that gives me the creeps.
And I don´t Know what it is.
I mean, Audrey Hepburn is
glorious and I --
but it´s just true --
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Look, if you´re creeped out,
you´re creeped out.
That´s just -- there´s no
getting around that.
-I really think that is true.
-Another thing that strikes me
as it was very personal
was the music choices.
-Yes.
-For those who don´t know,
when there´s a song
you really want in a movie,
you have to get permission
to use it.
And you personally reached out
to some people via letters?
-Yes, I wrote some letters.
-Like, for example, there´s --
and I do feel like
these songs were very --
they kind of
had to be those songs.
-Yes, they had to -- I had
written them into the script.
They were very specifically
those songs.
-And so you wrote
Alanis Morissette a nice letter.
And what were some of
your selling points to her?
-Well, so, "I have been a fan of
yours my whole life.
The very first cassette tape
I ever bought was
´Jagged Little Pill.´
I would listen to ´Perfect´ over
and over in my living room,
memorizing the lyrics.
I remember bringing that same
cassette to a sleepover party
where we all played our favorite
songs for each other.
I played ´Hand in my Pocket´
because my mother told me
that ´Perfect´ might be
a little too heavy
for a fifth grade
slumber party."
[ Laughter ]
"I saw the film ´Dogma´ because
I read that you played God,
which seemed totally fitting
to me."
-Yeah, and you think "Breakfast
at Tiffany´s" is creepy?
-Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
This is an example of
my creepiness.
-No, but this was really great.
Wait, you have to --
You wrote Dave Matthews?
-Yes.
-And obviously you´ve moved on.
I like that you´ve moved on
from cassettes to CDs.
because you knew you couldn´t
tell him
it was his first cassette?
-Yeah, this is -- I say, "These
were my very first CD purchases.
[ Laughter ]
And I made my dad take me to see
you and your band perform
when you came to Sacramento."
So -- and I said -- I said
that the song "Crash into Me,"
which is the song in the movie,
was the most romantic song ever,
underlined.
[ Laughter ]
So I -- And I was --
And then I said,
"Thank you so much for
considering the request.
I wish I could go back in time
and tell my 16-year-old self
that this moment was coming.
She´d never believe me,
but truth be told,
my 32-year-old self
can hardly believe it either."
[ Laughter ]
-I like that the moment
you can´t believe is
that you´re writing him
a letter.
-I know. I can´t believe it.
Can´t believe my letter.
-And Justin Timberlake,
as well, and they all said yes.
-Yes!
Oh, the Justin Timberlake --
That has
a really awkward beginning.
-Oh, yeah, let´s --
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I got it here.
I like that you´re embracing
your awkwardness.
-Okay, so,
"Dear Mr. Timberlake --
[ Laughter ]
I mean, what can I say?
You´re Justin Timberlake."
[ Laughter ]
"You were the soundtrack
to my adolescence.
Your rise corresponded exactly
with my very awkward puberty."
[ Laughter ]
-And then it just gets worse.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. "I pretty much wouldn´t be
an adult without you."
That´s the nicest thing
you could say to anyone.
That´s heartbreak-- when your
parents -- when they hear that,
they´ll be heartbroken.
-They´ll be like, "This was
Justin Timberlake´s doing?
What were we doing
all that time?"
-Well, I´m glad it paid off
because it´s hard now to imagine
the film without those songs.
-Yeah.
-And congratulations on making
such a beautiful film.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Greta Gerwig, everybody.